merci beaucoup d'être avec nous venu
d'être notre invité politique ce matin
député du nord porte parole du
rassemblement national porte parole de
la campagne de marine le pen on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale à montpellier ce
matin on retrouve vincent coste du midi
libre bonjour vincent merci beaucoup
bonjour avec joue pour cette cité le
groupe bien sûr longuement parlé de la
campagne présidentielle henri des
meetings de ce week-end sébastien chenu
mais d'abord un mot sur l'ukraine et sur
la russie puisque emmanuel macron
rencontre aujourd'hui vladimir poutine
il se rendra en ukraine demain il veut
tenter de trouver une solution
diplomatique au conflit entre les deux
pays est ce que vous soutenez son
initiative mais elle arrive bien tard
vous savez la crau avait rencontré
vladimir poutine au début de son mandat
ils le rencontrent aujourd'hui au moment
où finalement il achève ce quinquennat
et entre les deux que s'est il passé pas
grand chose on n'a pas le sentiment que
la france était beaucoup à l'initiative
durant ces années c'est d'ailleurs l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles je pense les
russes ont du mal à comprendre ce qu'a
fait emmanuel macron ou quel est le sens
de sa politique diplomatique sur ces
dernières années puisque ça a été
quelqu'un de très évanescent sap a été
un partenaire très solide et on a eu le
sentiment que la france a été un peu en
deuxième catégorie pour revenir en
première catégorie faut pas se comporter
j'allais dire comme un vassal mais comme
un intermédiaire aurait pas en première
catégorie combat c'est un peu tard sous
les on a vu que c'était quand même les
etats unis la grande bretagne qui
étaient à la manoeuvre et nous on est un
peu spectateur alors que je pense que
notre rôle c'est d'être un intermédiaire
solide dans cette crise moi je ne crois
pas ou on nous nous parlons à une guerre
possible pour plein de raisons d y
compris des raisons objectives
d'ailleurs on voit qu'il ya pas il ya
introduit des militaires qui sont massés
à la frontière mais par exemple n'y a
pas d'hôpital de campagne etc donc on
voit bien que c'est plutôt une pression
qui est mise mais je pense que la france
aurait gagné à être effectivement cet
intermédiaire on a perdu du temps et
emmanuel macron le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est qu'il n'ait pas été un
diplomate hors pair durant ces cinq
années entre les pays avec lesquels on a
perdu du crédit ce qui nous ont humiliés
sa crème pas été brillants vincent une
question là dessus
oui le président de la république
n'est pas officiellement encore candidat
il justifie le fait de ne pas être
candidat par l'activité qui le mène sur
le sur le front international et aussi
par là par les réponses qui doit qui
doit apporter à la crise sanitaire s'est
justifié selon vous c'est quelque chose
qui peut qui peut être entendu ce ce
retard de 200 entrée en campagne par
rapport à ces motifs la qui la vente ont
coûté je crois que personne n'est dupe
je le disais en début
d'intervention emmanuel macron on l'a
pas vue en russie pendant cinq ans là il
surgit tel un diable qui sort de la
boîte en disant ah mais nous sommes là
aussi c'est un peu tard et ça lui donne
un prétexte pour ne pas annoncer sa
candidature
ah oui c'est plutôt dans ce sens là
qu'il faut le dire emmanuel macron
s'agite s'agit de beaucoup tout ça pour
nous faire croire qu'il a une activité
très importante et qu'il ne veut pas
dire qu'il est candidat aux élections
présidentielles personne n'est dupe
offert n'est pas un français qui pensent
que macron sera pas candidat aux
élections présidentielles donc emmanuel
macron s'agisse elle sera candidate de
facto puisqu'il a dépassé les 500
parrainages et par exemple aussi mais je
veux dire il s'agit c'est à dire qu'un
couple il est à l'international où ils
essayent de remuer les choses alors
qu'on l'a pas vue pendant cinq ans un
coup il est en province il était la
semaine dernière dans le nord pas de
calais pour faire des annonces c'est un
peu tard là aussi au bout de cinq ans
vraiment ce sont des rideaux de fumée
personne n'est dupe et sincèrement c'est
pas très loyal c'est pas très
respectueux ni des électeurs ni la
démocratie et on attendrait des modèles
macron un peu plus de courage on
attendrait d'un président de la
république sortant qui va se représenter
qu'ils le disent qu'ils viennent
débattre c'est un manque de courage pour
vous le tabbee ce soleil qui ne se
seraient non on dit dax allemand c'est
un manque de courage quand j'entre
opposant la république ne compte pas se
soumettre un débat contradictoire avec
ses adversaires sincèrement c'est une
façon une mauvaise manière faite aux
français du coup marine le pen non plus
marie le pen débattre avec emmanuel
macron et les autres candidats
elle a demandé également à débattre par
exemple avec valérie pécresse parce que
on nous dit que dans les sondages elles
sont au coude à coude alors nous et je
le répète ici d'ailleurs sur votre
plateau à nous lançons cette invitation
à valérie pécresse qu'elle est dans une
stratégie de l'évitement même pécresse
doit pas avoir grand chose à dire on la
voit nulle part elle se faufile elle
sort pas d'île de france le demain le
val de marne le meeting à paris elle
sorte à les cadenasser en ile de france
est un il était en champagne ardenne
ça n'a pas été très on n'a pas entendu
grand chose mais surtout qu'elles
viennent débattre aussi valérie pécresse
c'est incroyable ces candidats quand
même président de la république aux
dames pécresse qui veulent présider aux
destinées de la france et qui refusent
de débattre c'est à dire de mettre sur
la table leurs propositions de nous
expliquer comment ils vont faire leur
bilan il manquerait aujourd'hui il a un
bilan dont on pourrait parler longuement
aucun président candidat à sa propre
succession n'a participé à un débat de
garder mon premier nommé d'accord mais
enfin madame la crise nous ai pas
raconté qu'il était le nouveau monde que
sa lettre est différent qu'avec lui on
allait voir ce qu'on allait voir
remarquez nous avait dit aussi que
c'était un économiste hors pair c'est
bon on a vu que c'était un diplomate
extraordinaire merci on a vu donc
effectivement c'est un démocrate
absolument redoutable absolument moderne
puisque désormais il refuse le débat
donc effectivement ce nouveau monde il
est pire que l'ancien finalement en fait
il a tous les travers de ses
prédécesseurs alors à revenir sur le
meeting de marine le pen ce week-end à
reims ce qu'on retient finalement de ce
métier c'est ce moment personnel elle
s'est livrée à la fin les sorties de son
pupitre elle s'est avancée sur la scène
et elle s'est livrée sur sa vie sur son
parcours sur sa vie de mère sur son
parcours politique
est ce qu'au bout de la troisième
campagne avait une nécessité de fond de
l'armure pour al mais je crois que ce
qui était intéressant c'est que
marine le pen a fait à travers cet acte
de sincérité l' inverse de ce qu'ont
fait certains de ses prédécesseurs en
campagne qui venaient nous raconter
qu'ils avaient changé rappelez-vous
nicolas sarkozy j'ai changé que ça non
mais on change pas en été on peut
s'améliorer et marine le pen est venue
dire j'ai appris je suis tombé je me
suis relevé voilà qui je suis j'ai
appris de tout ça j'ai appris de ses
années passées
à batailler j'ai appris de ses années
passées à tempêter elle a dit d'ailleurs
moi je ne veux plus du bruit de la
fureur je veux faire les choses
sérieusement et je crois qu'elle a voulu
démontrer que sa vie son parcours a été
faite de hauts de bas de difficultés
personnelles et politiques comme tous
les français et qu'elle en avait tiré
quelque chose parce que ça qui est
important c'est de tirer de ces
expériences
comment ça a été
d'abord pourquoi parce que je pense que
n est plus très loin de gagner en
réalité dans les sondages qui la placent
au second tour marine le pen n'est plus
très loin de gagner nous n'avons jamais
été aussi haut et je rappelle que le
week-end dernier nous dépassions valérie
pécresse au second tour dans les
intentions de vote au second tour face à
emmanuel macron donc macron vous êtes
toujours perdons aujourd'hui mais aucun
modèle macron se déclarent qu'ils
viennent faire campagne qu'ils viennent
proposer qu'ils viennent débattre et on
verra à ce moment là donc pourquoi parce
que je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous ne
sommes plus très loin et puis c'est
nécessaire les français vont évidemment
pour des idées mais votent pas pour un
catalogue de promesses ils votent pour
une incarnation ils veulent savoir à qui
il confie les clés du pays et à marine
le pen ils ont le sentiment je crois de
confier le pays de mettre le pays entre
de bonnes mains ils veulent savoir qui
est cette femme qu'on a présenté souvent
comme une héritière politique
qu'ils ont sentiment de d'avoir vu
depuis de connaître depuis longtemps de
voir depuis longtemps sans forcément
connaître la femme qui est derrière en
rolls elle une élection présidentielle
c'est une incarnation c'est un rapport
direct au français sauf qu'avant ce
moment personnel qui était à la fin du
meeting j'ai eu tout un discours
discours dans lequel elle a quand même
présenté sa vision france alors elle a
parlé de la france des villes de la
france des villages elle a parlé pouvoir
d'achat et on a senti peu de réactions
dans la salle en tout cas moins d'
enthousiasme que lorsqu'elle évoquait
les sujets de l'immigration est ce que
vous ne vous êtes pas trompés de
messages dans ce discours ah non alors
je sais pas tout à fait d'accord avec
vous moi j'étais dans la salle est
d'abord on était cinq mille personnes
nous n'imaginions pas être autant il
faut bien le dire et marine le pen elle
a deux pieds sa campagne repose sur deux
pieds rendre aux français alors pays
rendre aux français leur argent ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire d'abord lutter
contre les idéologies qui nous font tant
de mal en isme le au moc isme
l'islamisme sein c'est rendre aux
français leur pays nous ne souhaitons
pas que notre pays soit autre chose de
ce qu'il est et puis nous ne souhaitons
pas que le pays et que notre pays que la
france soit autre chose que les français
ont construit à les français ils ont
construit avec leur travail avec leurs
efforts un pays avec des protections
sociales avec des équilibres et c'est
aujourd'hui ce sont ces équilibres qui
sont attaqués par les décisions du
président de la république on le voit
que le pouvoir d'achat enfin hier 1,76 à
la pompe le gasoil on se rend compte
c'est beaucoup plus d'ailleurs que le
pli qui avait fait sortir les gilets
jaunes sur les ronds-points et c'est là
dessus que les attentes des électeurs
bah c'est la préoccupation numéro un des
français que celle du pouvoir d'achat
alors il y en a d'autres
l'immigration la sécurité la santé le
logement ce sont des préoccupations
fortes mais le pouvoir d'achat
aujourd'hui est au coeur des
préoccupations des français d'ailleurs
c'est bien compréhensible une fois que
je suis soigné ou que j'ai chapeau que
vides qui est telle qu'ils la grande
angoisse de nos compatriotes comment je
vis comment je mange quelle est ma
qualité de vie comment j'élève mes
gamins je veux dire c'est la vallée y
ait autant de sujets ce qu'il y avait
aussi nécessité pour elle de montrer
qu'elle était une candidate crédible sur
tous les sujets sur d'autres sujets
comme l'immigration et la sécurité ne
pas laisser trop jeune pour vous oui
mais vous savez une élection
présidentielle c'est pas le début d'une
nouvelle aventure comme on pourrait
l'imaginer l'imaginer c'est la fin des
cinq ans passés en fait c'est la
conclusion de ce qui s'est passé pendant
cinq ans des macros il a un bilan bilan
de ces cinq ans il sera jugé sur ce
bilan et sur son projet marine le pen
est là quelque part 1 en opposante elle
a été enterrée sans foi elle est tombée
elle s'est relevé mais surtout elle a
travaillé pendant ces cinq années et
elle a construit un projet avec des gens
d'expérience et ce projet aujourd'hui il
répond à toutes les préoccupations des
français avant disait oui le
rassemblement national ou parler que de
sécurité et d'immigration eh bien nous
sommes aujourd'hui capables de parler de
santé de parler de logements de parler
de pouvoir d'achat de parler de ce qui
intéresse concrètement la vie des gens
parce que finalement quand on est
candidat c'est bien pour solutionner les
problèmes des gens c'est bien pour que
les français vivent mieux demain vincent
le pouvoir d'achat est la préoccupation
numéro un des français c'est vrai mais
également des américains des espagnols
des italiens par prudente dans des
proportions beaucoup plus inquiétante
qu'en france j'ai écouté le discours de
marine le pen ça me dit qu'ils dressent
un portrait un peu apocalyptique de
l'état de la france en 2022 vous pensez
vraiment que la france est dans cet état
qui a quand même quelques indicateurs
positifs à la sortie d'une la sortie de
crise que ce soit le chômage la la
croissance et les problèmes d'inflation
ne sont pas inhérents à la spécifique à
la france d'en haut on le note dans dans
tous les pays occidentaux le l'état réel
du pays est à ce point sombre et
désespéré
honnêtement que le bilan des modèles
macron n'est pas bon en particulier
économiquement il n'est pas bon en
matière de sécurité et d'immigration
vous avez vu les chiffres qui sont
sortis ces jours ci c'est apocalyptique
d'ailleurs on n'entend plus gérald
darmanin en ce moment même où il est
passé d'habitude on sortait il allait
faire quelques tweets etc aujourd'hui
ministre de l'intérieur qui a
complètement disparu de la circulation
mais économiquement
nouveau cfcm ce week end une femme oui
d'accord ok on aurait beaucoup à dire
aussi là dessus non mais d'abord
économiquement quand vous dites monsieur
le chômage a baissé enfin en catégorie a
b c quand même prendre ces trois
catégories en compte on a aujourd'hui
plus de demandeurs d'emplois qu'on en
avait au début du quinquennat des
modèles macron et puis surtout moi j'ai
le sentiment n'a pas le sentiment
d'ailleurs je vois ce café modèle macron
il a transformé notre économie il a eu
beau risée notre économie il est un
élève zélé du libéralisme il est un
libéral excessif il est un libéral à
tout crin et aujourd'hui modèle macron
il a évidemment transformé notre
économie c'est-à-dire que quand je dis
la numériser il a créé un nouveau
prolétariat les chauffeurs über les
livreurs délit verrous ce nouveau larbi
n'a de notre société mâcon mais bien sûr
il a accéléré tout ça parce qu'en fait
il a fait en sorte que notre économie ne
repose plus que sur des emplois qui ne
sont pas pérennes que sur la débrouille
que sur l'idée demain peut-être de
travailler avec d'avoir deux ou trois
emplois mais c'est la philosophie
déconstructive des modèles macron c'est
un libéral à tout crin et lui ça
l'ennuie pas d'ailleurs vous le savez
c'est le candidat de
l'interchangeabilité avec le maquereau
tout doit être interchangeables vous
êtes boucher charcutier lundi à vierzon
vous devez devenir esthéticienne le
mardi à biarritz dire que vous devez
changer de boulot de l'endroit dans
lequel vous vivez vous devez vous
attacher à rien mais c'est ça la
philosophie d'emmanuel macron celle d'un
quai l'on ne s'attache à rien la loi sur
la crise sanitaire oui mais finalement
aussi le libéral à tous crins aussi
celui qui a mis en place le quoi qu'il
en coûte et qui a usé de l'état
providence comme peut-être aucun autre
chef d'état avant lui ce qu'est ce qui
est ce qui est quand même complètement
contradictoire avec la la doctrine
ultralibérale que quand vous décrivez
est de la même façon le la crise de
sanitaires j'ai été frappé dans le
discours notamment de de marine le pen
samedi il en est très peu question alors
que c'était c'est quand même le
l'événement le plus inouï de ces
dernières décennies et qui a touché la
la planète entière c'est c'est quelque
chose qui vous gé dedans d'en parler
puisque globalement la france la hausse
ici aussi on des zooms un peu s'en sort
plutôt pas trop mal en ayant habité de
confinement des restrictions plus
sévères ces derniers mois dont à ce
sujet qui est aussi une autre
préoccupation majeure des français et il
est aussi présent dans les discours
celui de marine le pen comme celui
d'eric zemmour d'ailleurs qu'il a qui
l'avait précédé non alors d'abord
évidemment marine le pen n'allait pas
dans son discours vous raconter qu'il
faut faire qu'il faut obtenir les gestes
barrière maîtres hamas enfin je pense
qu'on est passé à quelque chose d'autre
en revanche je pense qu'elle a expliqué
fondamentalement ce que cette crise
avait dévoilé mis en lumière de notre
société c'est la ruine de l'hôpital
public est d'ailleurs la déconstruction
des services publics elle est aussi la
feuille de route des modèles macron à
quand vous pensez que pendant cette
crise le gouvernement a fermé plus de
5000 lits tout au long de cette crise eh
bien je pense que c'est ça que dit la
crise du coc vide elle dit que notre
hôpital public que ce soit d'ailleurs la
rumeur de la revalorisation qui n'a pas
eu lieu à travers le ségur des emplois
de santé la crise de gestion et de
direction de l'hôpital public les moyens
qui ne sont pas mis en adéquation avec
les besoins le coc vide a révélé l'état
de notre hôpital public et marine le pen
dans son discours a parlé de l'idée
qu'elle se fait d'un service public de
la santé demain oui c'est un service qui
a demandé des moyens et notamment pour
la fin de vie d'ailleurs si on dépasse
même s'ils ont des zooms pour reprendre
votre expression
le coc vide la santé au sens large
préoccupation importante des français
c'est aussi la fin de vie les
propositions qu'on a fait sur les ehpad
on n'a pas attendu là encore une
actualité brûlante donc je pense que le
coc vide a été le révélateur des
faiblesses de notre société et force est
de constater que en matière de santé le
gouvernement n'a pas été à la hauteur
durant ces années marine le pen à la
citer 1 la cible est un adversaire
samedi c'est emmanuel macron elle a
parlé de la france orange ma chronique
pas un mot sur les autres candidats
notamment sur eric zemmour est ce que
vous n'êtes pas en train de faire le
second tour avant le premier est ce que
pour le moment votre principal
adversaire ce n'est pas plutôt élisez
moi non mais eric zemmour il est dans
toutes les
les études d'opinion 4e si on fait une
moyenne eric zemmour n'est pas en
capacité d'aller au second tour et je
crois qu'il le sait lui-même
et puis
il faut que le même jour qui donne
marine le pen à 18% eric zemmour à 13 je
crois qu'il reste bourse est qu'il ne
peut pas aller au second tour mais il
sait et c'est peut-être son objectif
qu'il peut faire battre marine le pen
peut-être que c'est davantage son
objectif pour demain reconstituer une
espèce de partis de droite d'union des
droites à nous ça nous intéresse pas du
tout
cas il n'est pas celui de gagner
puisqu'il sait qu'il ne peut pas gagner
mais je pense qu'il sait qu'il peut
empêcher marine le pen de gagner pour
après en 2027 2028 2030 de construire
une union des droits très sincèrement
c'est pas notre objectif à nous il était
survenu ce week-end dans le nord lui
pour faire son meeting il était sur vos
terres il a parlé de vottem qu'avec des
fonds marine le pen dans cette campagne
le travail le pouvoir d'achat ce qui
n'est pas en train de marcher sur nos
plates bandes mais il en parle avec
tellement peu de crédibilité ça a été
tellement peu réfléchi quand je vois les
propositions qu'il fait sur une prime et
vous vous dites que ça va faire baisser
les salaires c'est pas du il se sera pas
peretz a pas donné de pouvoir d'achat ça
te permettra pas aux français de se
loger parce que lorsqu'on fait un prêt
pour un logement c'est pas parce que
nous toucher une prime un dans votre
entreprise qu'on va vous accorder le
prêt c'est tellement pas sérieux que je
crois que aujourd'hui les français ils
attendent de candidats et c'est
peut-être la raison pour laquelle marine
le pen cible et maunel macron ils
attendent de candidats qu'il soit
sérieux qu'ils soient solides qu'ils
soient cohérents et finalement marine le
pen elle est effectivement l'opposé
total d' emmanuel macron son parcours sa
personnalité ses propositions son
entourage tout la différencie des
modèles macron sa vision de la france
dans le monde tout la différence y est
je pense que pécresse et émaux sont des
sous traitants ce sont des sous
traitants valérie pécresse une sous
traitante à des modèles macron eric
zemmour est un sous-traitant de mari le
pen avec des excès ou une radicalité qui
est assumée de son côté mais les
français vont pas voter pour des
sous-traitants vont pas voter pour des
déclinaisons ils vont voter pour des
hommes et des femmes en l'occurrence
probablement un homme et une femme et un
homme accro marine le pen qui ont des
projets pour le pays qui sont tellement
différents radicalement différente
qu'effectivement il nous amèneront le
pays a des résultats très différents
c'est vrai que nous nos objectifs les
objectifs de marine le pen c'est grosso
modo être plus exigeants vis-à-vis de
l'union européenne d'avoir moins
d'immigration plus de sécurité plus de
pouvoir d'achat il n'y a pas tromperie
sur la marchandise avec marine le pen
quand on va de bart une opel on sait à
peu près ce qu'on aura moins d'union
européenne moins d'immigration plus de
sécurité plus de pouvoir d'achat c'est
assez simple c'est assez carré je ne
suis pas sûr que lorsqu'on vote pour les
adversaires de marine le pen on sache
exactement à quel est le programme la
déclinaison et l'offre au bout du compte
un examen sous traitants mais diète sous
traitants oui oui au dernier pointage du
conseil constitutionnel vous avez 35
parrainage marine le pen à 35 parrainage
on est très loin des 500 nécessaire est
ce que vous êtes sûr qu'on pourrait être
candidate alors aujourd'hui nous sommes
à peu près à 430 promesses mais nous
considérons qu'il nous faut au moins 100
signatures de plus et c'est très
difficile beaucoup de maires ne veulent
signer pour personne le système il est
vraiment verrouillé et nous avons une
vraie difficulté et moi j'appelle les
maires à jouer ce rôle ils peuvent jouer
différentes façons il s'agit pas de
parrainer quelqu'un dont vous partagez
les convictions quand on pense que
madame arthaud de lutte ouvrière va
avoir ses parrainages on peut pas
imaginer que marine le pen ne les ai pas
c'est un risque pourtant et elle ce
risque il existe et moi je dis au maire
assumer cette responsabilité
il ne s'agit pas de se retrancher
derrière un avis du conseil municipal
j'entendais mère qui me les a vus mais
le conseil municipal ne veut pas s'agit
d'assumer une responsabilité qui encore
une fois n'a rien à voir et tes
convictions mais on ne peut pas imaginer
je pense que présente la république
aurait beaucoup de mal à être crédible
si dans notre pays marine le pen ne
pouvait pas être candidate parce que le
système aurait verrouillé ce dispositif
d'un film que la deuxième lisa sion n'a
pas marché et finalement vous voyez que
les maires ils sont réticents à paraître
je pense que c'est un signe des
pressions qui sont exercées sur un
certain nombre de maires présidents
d'agglo de présente département qui
disent attention si vous signez pour la
candidate qui aurait été peut battre
l'ol macron c'est ennuyeux fait
attention à ton budget aura pas ta
subventions et les maires veulent pas se
mettre dans ces situations là donc moi
je pense qu'il faut à un moment que tout
le monde revienne à des choses bien sans
s'est marié le pen a besoin des
signatures nous continuerons à
solliciter les maires nous leur
demandons de jouer ce jeu de la
démocratie parce que je pense que
l'absence de candidature de marine le
pen délégitimerait totalement cette
élection présidentielle enfin je pense
que personne ne pourrait pas de
légitimité de l'élection à présent
candidate qui présente des qui est
présente à toutes les élections depuis
30 ans à tous les scrutins qui
rassemblait des millions de voix qui est
allé au second tour de la dernière fois
qu'ils seraient verrouillé par le
progrès le dispositif des 500 signatures
alors même que madame arthaud monsieur
asselineau eux pourraient concourir
alors qu'on peut s'en sort mépris dire
qu'il représente beaucoup moins de
français ça pose quand même un problème
grâce à une dernière question
est ce signe peut-être la
dédiabolisation n'a pas complètement
abouti demain elle avait déjà eu du mal
du mal je crois qu'elle avait eu 6 180
650 signatures quelque chose que quelque
chose comme ça là c'est vrai qu'à la
droite ce qu'on peut appeler la droite
radicale à la droite des républicains il
ya plusieurs candidats avec eric zemmour
en plus avec pour peut-être dupont
aignan et c'est le
potentiel de deux 2 candidats sur ces
positionnements s'est élargi vous avez
perdu des élus aussi aux élections
départementales régionales
ça s'explique peut-être mécaniquement
aussi le fait de plutôt que par un
complot du système non mais j'ai pas
parlé de complot et j'utilise jamais ce
genre de terme jamais je dis que le
système verrouille les choses mais
mécaniquement oui on a aussi perdu des
élus régionaux il ya une offre politique
et plus l'âge aussi évidemment ça ajoute
aux difficultés mais je pense quand je
dis que le système verrouillé les choses
il n'y il y avait la possibilité
sincèrement de lever de rendre par don
anonyme c'est signature le gouvernement
n'a pas souhaité le faire enfin qu'est
ce que ça apporte finalement 7 cet
anonymat qui est levé aujourd'hui 6
2 500 maires vous en aviez un peu plus
de six ans ça veut dire que quasi tous
vos parrainages été rendue publique dès
j'arrive d'accord mais pas en aurait eu
davantage c'était c'était différent mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que faut pas
perdre de vue quel est l'objectif quel
est le but d'une élection présidentielle
et de ses parrainages ses parrainages
ils sont faits pour écarter des
candidats dits jeu reprend les propos de
certains folklorique et résultats on est
en train d'essayer ou peut-être sera
privé de caunes nature une candidate qui
représente des millions de français et
des candidats que certains qualifient de
folklorique ce que je ne voyais pas de
mépris dans ma bouche moi je les
qualifie pas ainsi mais qui représente
très peu d'électeurs vont se retrouver
candidats il ya un problème merci merci
merci sébastien chaigneau
[Musique]